hello I'm Nick arendelle and the audio
director Rocksteady Studios the number
one skill you need to be successful
audio director is to work hard I hope
you're doing your best here because I
just had a horrible we can actually die
here tonight the beginning is lots of
planning so we never kind of blunder
into something we do an awful lot of
planning initially it's that stage I
find the hardest to be honest you we
need to work out what we need to record
what we can do internally if we need to
go somewhere to record something so
initially there's a rather a lot of of
planning there's then a production stage
where we're actually doing and that's
the bit I can kind of I really enjoy and
kind of shine I think that's when you're
working with the levels you're playing
the game you're seeing recent levels
that perhaps a change perhaps something
new has been added so it's 210 something
aware but that's the bit where you're
actually doing we get to a point I guess
fairly early in production whereby we
have pretty much the full game there and
then there's a process of polish going
back over stuff finding out that the
ideas you had in the planning stage
weren't quite right you then go back
polish we polish and then at the end
there's like a long fairs of sitting in
a dark room the towel of your head you
know kind of at the end veiled it's like
wow it's finished I collaborate most
with the audio department obviously the
guys that the cord is there the sound
designers they're also the people
external to us so the external composer
the external sound designer within the
team I guess it's people like Paul
Crocker the lead narrative designer the
Cinemax lead animation lead it's all the
kind you know sound support every other
department so you work really closely
with every other head if it's via
effects or animation
anything sound supports their idea right
so yeah everyone really there's a
process of reviews whereby we make sure
were chewing that production fares were
always reviewing what we've done we
never just do something and assume it's
working in game and often you know
you'll find with that planning stage
that that what you thought would work in
reality it's not actually such a great
idea after all so then you need to think
on your feet and quickly get another
solution you know sound often provides
certainly and again like how come
sitting what we tried to do its provide
a kind of to things like a real
interpretation of the world so if you
open a door it makes a door opening
sound so that you're fleshing out the
believability of the world but I think
in a way that's the easy thing really
what we try and do with the zone is have
a kind of a subtext so we provide
something about that doll
so perhaps what's on the other side of
the door so there's door opening sound
doesn't just tell you that you're
opening a door which you it needs to do
right but it also tells you something
about what's on the other side of the
door we mostly use Rocksteady in the
audio department it's different for
different things we have a fairly
standard third-party bit of middleware
called W wise which is our kind of
interface to getting sound into the game
all the asset creation is done in Pro
Tools
unless it's composition and then we do
that and logic certainly at the
beginning we spend a long time
researching different areas so we'll get
early concept art from the artist
they'll say we want to build a city you
know a torture chamber any of the
various dungeons in Arkham City and then
we'll have to find somewhere appropriate
to record for that so we spent a lot of
time researching various places we
recorded in a cave system we did some
location recording museum for fairground
attractions to support the Gurkha fide
steel mill area were recorded in a steel
mill initially we do an awful lot of
research into locations that we can get
access to to record that will hopefully
provide us with the sounds we need so I
guess since I started in the industry
the role hasn't really changed
tremendously what has changed are
people's abilities certainly from home
to create much more believable demos the
kind of that the progress in digital
music certainly when I first started the
kind of features we've got now even
something is kind of common dares time
stretching or pitch shifting that just
wasn't really an option certainly not
with the computers we had then now you
can you can buy for a relatively small
amount all the equipment you need to
produce quite an amazing demo so I guess
really what's happened is the rule
hasn't changed that much you're still I
would hope you're still directing people
kind of on both a creative and a kind of
realistic level but what has changed is
the the tools that we use have just
become so much more sophisticated
you